Pediatric surgeon Dr. James Stein is preparing to separate...
...two of the world's rarest conjoined twins, Macy and Mackenzie Garrison.
To be able to do this type of complex surgery is kind of a dream come true.
But there were lots of things that could go wrong.
Nine-month-old Macy on the left and Mackenzie on the right are a medical phenomenon.
They're only the second known case in the world of conjoined twins...
...born with a triplet sister.
They were adopted by Darla and Jeff Garrison, as much longed for daughters,...
...when they were just nine months old.
Madeline came out last,...
...five minutes after her conjoined twin sisters.
To prepare for surgery, the medical team is stretching Macy and Mackenzie's skin.
They'll use the extra tissue to help close their wounds.
Although genetically identical, the twins separate personalities are already forming.
Macy was maybe a little bit more timid.
Mackenzie was a little bit more the hard charger.
Macy would whimper.
Mackenzie would scream.
Macy and Mackenzie are also among the rarest types of conjoined twins: ischiopagus twins.
They each have a full set of internal organs but share a single pelvis,...
...and are conjoined up to the top of their rib cages.
Oh, why are you making that funny face?
What did I do wrong?
This makes separation particularly dangerous.